- Oh my gosh y'all I'm
so excited right now!
We're backstage okay.
About to see This Is Us
I'm so excited.
There's so much heart,
it's such a great show
I'm so super stoked.
My new neighbors. Oh hey! What's up
Chris Sullivan, Chrissy
Metz, what's going on?
- Look at that bunt.
- Neighbor, I'm a neighbor now so I
brought y'all a bunt cake.
- Amazing.
- All right so I know that your show is so
beautiful and it's heart, it's all about
you know, y'all. This Is Us, right?
Everybody loves it but I thought,
I'm your new neighbor so
like maybe you wanna like
about me like this is me
like maybe I don't know.
Are you into it?
- Yeah, no no no please.
- All right well since we're neighbors
I'll just let you know
in case gifts come up
um, I like quilting, I like ear candling,
I like wine, um, I do have
um abnormally short arms
kinda like T-Rex, really they're not like
my height and they're supposed to be.
I have four children and I love denim.
I love denim.
- Thank you so much.
- Yes. Yeah. So that's
just a little bit about me.
- Fantastic.
- So I wanna do a little game with y'all.
I wanna know who are
you, dog or cat person?
- Dog.
- Oh I love y'all. Coffee or tea?
- Coffee.
- Tea.
- Yes! Chrissy for the win.
Vanilla or chocolate?
- Chocolate.
- Vanilla.
- Oh, that's hard!
- Vanilla bean.
- Nice! Chrissy and I are friends.
Can you sing your favorite musical notes?
And your favorite key?
- [Singing] Middle C
- Can you do it?
- No. No.
[Continues Singing]
- And, good.
Okay, go to dance move?
- I like the Carlton.
- Yes!
- It's like a casual, like a casual.
Not a big arm swing. Like a
- Mine's just sorta like
- It's almost like a, a wake me up
- Get in the groove.
- Kind of a wake me up before you go go
- Just like welcoming
- What's your favorite spirit animal?
- Oh uh uh Nick Offerman.
- I love him!
- Yeah, he's my spirit animal.
- That is great! Who's your spirit animal?
- It's like a dolphin
- Dolphin? That's sweet, that's kind
- They're congenial, they're sweet.
- They're so great, they're helpful.
- My spirit animal is Dixie Carter from
Designing Women. Just
if you wanted to know.
- Perfect.
- Who's you're favorite
new kid on the block?
- Joey
- Jordan Knight
- Oh my god! Okay so what's worse,
loud neighbor or like
overly friendly neighbor?
- Loud neighbor
- Okay
- Good then you'll love me.
I am loud and overly friendly.
- Yeah but you brought bunt.
- I do, I bring bunt cake.
- Yeah. So it all works out.
- Well I am very excited
about being neighbors.
- Well put her there neighbor.
- And I'm a hugger. I'm a hugger. Get rid
of that handshake.
- So exciting.